Can you imagine a world where one day if you
need a new heart you could just order one
made just for you?
Sound like science fiction?
Well we’re not so far off.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Dudes, so something pretty cool just happened
in the wonderful world of science.
Researchers grew BEATING HEARTS FROM HUMAN
STEM CELLS.
Okay fine hyperbole, it’s not the whole
heart just a few beating cells.
BUT IT’S SO COOL.
In a study published in the journal Nature,
the researchers used human skin cells, turned
them into pluripotent cells and used physical
and chemical signals to coax the cells into
forming little cardiac microchambers.
Which could be important for studying how
the heart grows in an embryo or how drugs
might affect a fetus’s heart.
Or… looking way into the future, for growing
hearts in a dish.
It could be a great way to replace organs.
No more waiting for a donor and since it would
be perfect match to your body, no more terrible
drugs to prevent rejection.
So far smaller organs like tracheas and bladders
have been grown in a lab using a person’s
own stem cells, but a heart is a little more
complicated.
So let’s take a little look into how we
got here.
First off, what are stem cells?
Stem cells are pluripotent, meaning they are
undifferentiated cells that can develop into
any kind of cell.
Skin, heart, liver etc.
So alright, but what’s the big deal?
Why do researchers love to study stem cells?
Even from the earliest inklings of stem cells,
there have been big dreams.
Researchers have hoped that one day they could
be able to grow entire new organs from stem
cells that would be a perfect match for the
recipient.
We’ve come a long way from the early days
of stem cell research.
Human stem cells were first isolated in 1998
by two independent research teams led by James
A. Thomson of the University of Wisconsin
and another by John D. Gearhart of Johns Hopkins
University School of Medicine.
These early stem cell lines were derived from
early embryos, which are destroyed in the
process and thus stirred a little controversy.
Okay a lot of controversy.
Because of the debate that raged in the US
surrounding embryonic stem cell research,
scientists looked to find stem cells in other
adult tissues.
So a few years later in 2001 adult stem cells
were found in fat tissue.
Now adult stem cells can be found from almost
any tissue.
But they are tricky, they take a while to
coax into growing in a dish.
So they’re not ideal.
But in 2007, in a paper published in the journal
Nature Biotechnology, Dr. Anthony Alata discovered
that amniotic fluid also contains stem cells.
Which of course added more fuel to the debate.
And the same year, two independent teams of
researchers pioneered a process to turn adult
somatic cells into pluripotent stem cells,
naturally called induced pluripotent stem
cells.
The process involves introducing 4 different
genes into the cells using a virus as a carrier.
The team from Japan led Shinya Yamanaka, published
their work in the journal Cell and the team
from by James Thomson at University of Wisconsin–Madison
published their work in the journal Nature.
And it was such a huge deal that, Yamanaka
actually won the 2012 Nobel Prize for discovering
iPS cells.
Which of course this discovery held a lot
of promise, it would sidestep some of the
controversy with embryonic stem cells.
But there are more than a few issues with
their technique, like low efficiency, it’s
difficult to do and when done, only a few
cells are reprogrammed.
Plus there’s weird problems with rejection
and also a problem with tumors developing.
But problems aside, tons of studies have been
and are being done with this technology.
With lofty goals, like attempting to cure
blindness and diabetes.
The Federation of American Societies for Experimental
Biology says that IPS cells will also “allow
scientists to study complex human diseases
in Petri dishes, a step toward analyzing the
conditions and developing therapies.”
Some researchers like Dr. Alata don’t care
where the cells come from, just that they
work well.
No matter where stem cells come from, it’s
clear that we’re on the road to organs grown
in a dish.
Well I certainly hope so.
But it’s also clear that more research is
needed.
And really, lab grown organs can’t come
soon enough!
If you wanna know the challenges of living
with an organ transplant & why they fail,
check out this recent video
I did: